for anyone that sort of thinks that Free
Speech exists without any caveats uh you
know I would just urge you to walk into
uh most political conferences and say
free Palestine and see what happens yeah
I'm not joking you want to talk red
lines let's talk red lines 100% 100% red
L yeah Palestine never gets called
councel culture no but tck gbru you
probably never heard of her she got
fired from Google because she said that
one of the real problems with AI is it's
going to be programmed by white
middle-aged men so it's going to have an
inbuilt bias they fired her for that did
the daily maale pick up her it didn't
for two reasons one they're all white
middle-aged men I don't really care
about it and two she is an a woman of
color from Ethiopia so there's these
double standards that go on with regard
to cancel culture that give you the the
clue about what it's really
about